don't waste your money or time or risk
an upset stomach or hours on the toilet
go elsewhere
do we really want to try this
it was i was
shocking
i really wanted it to be good
everybody i'm jordan and i'm half
italian and i'm tucker and i spent a
month in italy last summer with my
girlfriend today we will be trying three
of new york's worst reviewed pizza
slices if they deserve a second chance
or if they deserve redemption then we
will be leaving them a nice review and
revealing the name of the place it's a
second chance it's slice
[Music]
hands down one of the worst pizzas i've
ever had cheers
[Music]
so like the cheese is gluey
bottom isn't really that cooked either
the people there were really nice
um the crust is dry
i think this place is going to stay
anonymous
yeah this pizza would be good for if
you're looking for a pizza place you
could go into and
take pictures of it yes very aesthetic
but i would say for our purposes
today it does not deserve a second
chance at [ __ ]
what a shame
[Music]
some of the worst pizza i've had in nyc
they use so little cheese it barely
covered the slice
like what you get on an old frozen pizza
[Music]
it's like
[Music]
very oregano forward like it tastes like
oregano the sauce is really sweet
it's definitely better than the first
one
i got the oregano yeah there's like a
lot of it
um
so i would say that this pizza is for
someone who loves oregano
i don't think this deserves a second
chance at slice either i want to say i
came into this thinking that i was going
to like every single piece of pizza in
these two instances so far yelp's right
what a shame
this is the worst pizza i have had in my
lifetime of living in new york and new
jersey the crust tasted like toasted
white bread
it looks good it looks like visually
this one looks the best it's got like
little crusties on a little crusties
that's what i call them
i think i like this one
does the crust taste like toasted white
bread
[Music]
no
i think this one deserves a second
chance at slice it does i agree if
you're near the union square area in
manhattan hit up bravo pizza
[Music]
you're leaving mean reviews on bravo
pizza
stop
uh cheers
you